we're down here at the other side of the
11 bit Studios booth taken a look at
frost Punk the follow-up to this war of
mine well I wouldn't say maybe follow-up
because we don't want to look at it like
this war of mine 2.0 because that's not
the point
yeah such a game like this world of mine
it's a once in a lifetime right we're
not gonna make it we make any sequences
or so but it could be follow-up like
like you said because of the morals we
learned a lesson during this world of
mine development that will like
experimenting with topics or genres or
so on
and in this case with morality this
woman is a game about surviving war so
it asks you about what happens to
morality of people in in horrible cases
such as war but we're talking about
individuals to four maybe five you could
play a group of five in frost punk we
move to entire society so you play as a
leader of possibly the last city on
earth in frost Punk the story begins in
nineteenth century where we have
alternative version of history that the
world got frozen and you play as
possibly a leader of the last city like
it's the last stand of of civilization
so at the first glance it's a city
builder because you build this city
then the we've added a lot of survival
elements because you need to survive
you're the last stand of civilization so
we need to get coal wood steel and and
so on and food for your people and then
you can leave the city and explore the
world so we have exploration elements as
well but most importantly in my opinion
is that the most important layer is the
game about leaders so you set up laws
you make rules you are responsible for
the society you need to make hard
decisions like if you miss people if you
don't have enough people to work maybe
you send children to work if a lot of
people are sick do you move others from
getting resources to treat them but then
you don't have food right so maybe
you'll leave cripples and not treat them
so
as the leader sometimes you have to make
very brutal decisions because at the end
you believe you you see that the light
in the tunnel which is surviving this
this harsh winter so we in in this game
we experienced me with experiment pardon
me with morality of a leader what is the
cost of being a leader maybe what you
see is and you believe is good is not
good for the others but maybe you're
more clever so this game asks you if you
can foresee the future and be
responsible for other people if you
think you can do that so that that's the
challenge in frost Punk and as such I
believe is a it's a very serious game
and is like a spiritual follow-up to
this world of mine in looking at it one
of the one of the things that we noticed
that I noticed about it was that you're
sort of balancing two different forces
discontent and hope and thematically
it's about it seems to be about the
push-pull between those two forces in
society yeah because you know people
need hope they need to believe there's
there's the light at the end of the
tunnel right so they if you make a
promise to your people you need to
fulfill the promise otherwise they lose
hope so they need hope to be driven
forward you need to maintain hope right
on the other hand you have this content
and if this content is too high people
may go crazy and mutiny against your
open a rebellion and you're gonna lose
as a leader so you need to keep this
content relatively low but sometimes you
have to make hard decisions like sending
children to work for example like I
mentioned and there's gonna be this is
what makes people really angry so you
need to balance and think about each
your move all the time and I mentioned
earlier when we were talking off screen
that also your decisions shape the
society in the city even visually so
that's super interesting in frostbite
so you can shape the city and society
into different extremes this is pretty
interesting because that makes your mark
as a leader very distinctive so that
also has me relation to the game itself
because the game has an ending it's not
an endless City builder not at all it's
a story driven game in which you build a
city you try to survive and most
importantly you play as leader you shape
the society but there's an ending and at
the end you're gonna ask yourself what
kind of leader
have I been now between this war of mine
the the war child expansion and frost
pocket seems 11-bit is really aiming for
like really heavy subject matter and
yeah because we've finally figure out
that we're missing some substantial
element in games something that that
could provoke us to thinking like you're
playing a game you're done and they like
enjoyment in this case is over no we
want to make thought-provoking games
that that play with different emotions
in you as a player not necessarily
satisfaction but maybe relief maybe
thinking about yourself as what kind of
human you are and so on so we will not
provoke into such topics and this comes
from the fact that as the gamers we are
like thirty five-year-old guys for
something and we were missing some some
like I said some serious point if you
wanna let me relate it to film for
example if you're in a mood you watch a
comedy but there's a reason behind the
fact that you also watch Private Ryan
and you cry at the end right you desire
different kind of experiences so we
thought we we want to make such things
in games and this becomes somewhat our
speciality very matured topics very
serious guy games oriented towards
rather mature gamer I mean it's it's a
great niche that
filling in there and I certainly hope so
I like personally I'm a big fan of this
war of mine and my girlfriend in
particular my girlfriend in particular
is a huge fan of it she's played a lot
of it and I've lived almost vite more
vicariously through it thanks to her by
the way I will I'll let her know but
kind of what I wanted to say there's is
is that a lot of people like it's a it's
been a very popular game for like
streaming and and other forms of
experience that aren't necessarily
personally playing it because many
people find it too intense to play
themselves is that aspect that high
level of emotional intensity this sort
of drives people to want to maybe watch
it instead is that something that you've
noticed and thought about internally not
really a because it's because like you
said it's personal game so the way
people perceive them are so different
I've really heard people who who
invested themselves a lot but some they
were happy somewhere compassionate about
the characters they had in a game so the
perception is very very personal but on
the other hand yeah I heard a lot of
voices that yeah this game is so
emotionally convincing that investing in
it a lot means that I feel depressed at
the end and so on right but on the other
hand what we wanted to achieve at the
end of the game with that when you make
it you feel the relief this is the
moment where depression goes somewhere
away because there's there's the relief
right but I fully realized that it's not
a game for everyone and it should in me
all right when like what's sort of the
timeline on frost Punk where where's it
at and when can we expect it on what
platforms it's a long journey by now
because we started prototyping in early
2014 so imagine that after almost four
years by now we want to finish so which
should be out before the end of
year we done now a release date yet
because we have approach similar like
like like blizzard it's done when it's
done so we want to polish every pixel
until it shines every phrase every
coating and so on
and it's gonna be odd but the plan is
still to release it before the end of
the year
excellent thank you so much for talking
with me and again thank you for a good
word and please pass my greetings to
your girlfriend maybe she's gonna watch
it so well what's your name Laura Laura
thank you very good words I appreciate
it from you so cheers everyone